now that you know how to create an
arbitrarily complex nested layout it's
important to understand that they don't
come for free
once again the resource constraints of
the platform spoil the party inflating
complex layouts can be expensive
potentially impacting the performance
and responsiveness of your app so there
are two good rules of thumb to help
first keep your layouts shallow and wide
rather than deep and narrow that means
you're better off with more siblings and
fewer children because it's never as
simple as that you also want to avoid
having excessive views in those general
terms that means your activities full
hierarchy should never have more than
ten nested views or over 80 views in
total that probably sounds like a lot
but let's open up the hierarchy view a
tool in Android studio and see just how
quickly that can add up